wir müssen reden Liebe Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer über ein Problem der
Westen ist im Sinkflug sagt mein Freund
und Kollege ulfreller ulfi ernst meinst
du das ich glaube vor allem Europa ist
ein bisschen singt Flug und das fällt
einem nicht so leicht als Europa
Korrespondent das zu sagen aber man
spürt schon die Verunsicherung man hat
das Gefühl viele in Europa dass der
Zeitgeist vielleicht in die spricht oder
Chinesisch aber nicht mehr so wie wir
das früher gewohnt waren
an zwei Punkten würde ich das gerne
festmachen die auch den Gipfel hier
betreffen einmal der Ukraine Krieg
Zeitenwende ist ja das große Wort das
auch in Europa gilt und alle Europäer
denken eigentlich die Welt müsste sich
darum kümmern uns müsste klar sein dass
das die ganze Welt betrifft aber wenn
man das hier auf dem Gipfel sieht man
doch das ist wahrscheinlich dazu keine
einheitliche Erklärung gibt und dass die
Verurteilung des russischen
angriffskriegs immer weniger das Thema
vieler Länder hier ist und sagt lass uns
über andere Dinge reden und das andere
Thema uns kurz zusammenzufassen ist
Klima auch das soziale Thema in Europa
und wenn man sich Länder anguckt so
Giganten wie China oder auch Indien die
dann sagen wir haben unser eigenes Tempo
das wollen wir nicht so machen wie ihr
und bei Kohle wollen wir ausbauen also
diese zwei Themen zeigen es sind nicht
die Themen die Europa gerne gesehen
werden haben möchte so wie sie es sein
sollten sondern es gibt eine andere
Sicht drauf wie sagst du auf die
Eindrücke sind da die Stimmen gibt es
das sickert langsam durch Frage ist
natürlich hat man so viel Zeit anderswo
auf der Welt kommen die Dinge viel
schneller an und man will Antworten
hören man will endlich was geboten
kriegen was handfest ist natürlich auch
und hat Europa das
ob es Europa die anderen würde ich sagen
sagen wir haben unsere eigene
Zeitrechnung und die Europäer können
gerne ihre Zeitrechnung haben und müssen
gucken wie sie damit gesellschaftlich
auch quasi klarkommen für Europa ist es
natürlich extrem wichtig hier zu
überzeugen dass wir ja auch Olaf Scholz
kann Andy was dazu sagen weil nur gerade
das Thema Klima geht ja nur mit Indien
und China was wir in Europa machen ist
vielleicht wichtig aber nicht
entscheidend
im Singflug im Abschwung aber ich würde
noch nicht sagen dass da für die anderen
im Aufwind sind ja der Westen hat was
was ähm der globale Süden nicht hat und
der hat Einigkeit und zwar echt für mich
eine überraschende seit Russland die
Ukraine überfallen hat nehmen wir mal
die G7 als die Regierung des Westens die
haben sich Regierungswechsel
durchgemacht da ist in Italien die
postfaschistische Partei angemacht
gekommen in in Großbritannien
und trotzdem sind diese sieben so dicht
beieinander wie man es vielleicht noch
nie gesehen hat während der globale
Süden während die brex-staaten während
Indien China china könnte auch Indien
nicht das schwarze unter dem Fingernagel
wo ist denn der chinesische Präsident
hier also ja es sind schwere Zeiten für
den Westen aber ich sehe noch kein
Ersatz ich sehe ja noch kein
anderes Bündnis oder andere Regionen im
Aufwind ich sehe auch so ein bisschen
den Ukraine Konflikt als so nach
Katalysator Zeiten werden im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes weil das der Punkt war
wo vielleicht auch manche in Europa
aufgewacht sind das kannst du viel
besser beurteilen aber was mich dabei
umtreibt ist wenn der globale Süden sagt
und das weiß Normen vielleicht ganz
besonders gut wenn der sagt wir wollen
mehr Entwicklung wir wollen Teilhabe wir
wollen dass die Welt vorangebracht wird
dann will sie ja wollen die eigentlich
das gleiche wie der sogenannte Westen
will aber muss man sich nicht vorher
einmal auf einen grundprinzipium
verständigen das ist die territoriale
Integrität
kleines Landes und das betrifft nicht
nur die Ukraine sondern es betrifft wenn
man sich darauf verständigen würde und
es ist ja ein riesen Fragezeichen ob das
hier in die Abschlusserklärung kommt
betrifft natürlich dann auch alles
andere die kleinen Atolle die China
versucht zu okkupieren um da
Militärstützpunkte drauf zu bauen oder
vielleicht auch das Thema Taiwan und
vieles andere ganz kurz
sagen das Interesse können nur die etwas
kleineren Staaten haben die ganz großen
die Russen die Chinesen haben das
Interesse nicht dass das ähm in die
Abschlusserklärung kommt ja wobei z.B
indien ist ein großer würde ich mal
sagen ist der Gastgeber hier die hätten
eigentlich ein Interesse daran denn die
haben ja das Problem mit China selbst
die Chinesen greifen im Norden auf
indisches Territorium zu würden Sie
gerne es gibt laufen Grenzstreitigkeiten
das ist ein Konflikt der wirklich heiß
werden kann also indien hat selbst einen
Interesse aber es wird klein gehalten
und das wundert mich ein Stück weit auch
offenbar ist es so dass man an
verschiedenen anderen Stellen das als
wichtiger achtet sein eigenes Süppchen
zu kochen und zu profitieren und das tun
diese Mächte ja auch sie sind gefragt
von allen Seiten
und das spielen sie auch aus Indiens
gutes Beispiel dafür wie man profitieren
kann vielleicht gerade bei der territual
Integrität würde man sagen wer spricht
da wer Predigt also gerade auch Amerika
als ein großer ist er bei diesem Prinzip
mehrfach sündig geworden und der Westen
oder Europa hat dann ganz klein laut
weggekocht und es hat ein Satz noch auch
immer etwas süffisantes finde ich wenn
man den Haftbefehl von Putin zurecht
hochhebt und weiß dass es ein eine
Anklage gegen George Bush gibt oder das
muss eine große Verdächtigung und hat
keiner also Europa auch nicht seine
Werte eingeklagt die Sie jetzt den
anderen Predigt diese moralische
Doppelmoral hat für mich auch etwas mit
dem Schrumpfungsprozess zu tun weil die
nicht mehr so akzeptiert wird der wird
gesagt wer seid ihr uns zu predigen ich
glaube muss Europa darüber sich auch
klar werden ich glaube dass das größte
Problem von Joe Biden dass er dieses
ganze Vermächtnis einer jahrzehntelang
amerikanischen wie nennt man das
Kanonenboot Politik hatte wie Aron da
die Räume indische Autorin ja mal nach
dem 11 September gesagt hat der 11
September ist perfekte Folge davon aus
dieser Politik die Amerika aber so lange
Zeit gemacht hat aber das ist jetzt
meine gegen these sehen wir nicht gerade
dass Amerika bereit ist davon abzugehen
also ein Stück weit zu sagen wir müssen
gemeinsam die Probleme lösen und auch
wir Amerikaner können nicht diese
brachiale Machtpolitik so weitermachen
wie wir sie in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten gemacht haben also versuchen
Sie nicht gerade Glaubwürdigkeit zu
gewinnen und die große Frage ist gibt
der globale Süden denen die Chance das
zu tun und ist ein globale Süden auch
gewillt oder wer auch immer gewillt
diese Lücke dann auch zu füllen die sich
vielleicht bieteten da wird also
plötzlich was verlangt von den Staaten
es ist nicht mehr der einfache Position
zu sagen der Amerikaner ist da der wird
es irgendwie richten und dann das noch
zu bemängeln sondern plötzlich muss man
also selber was tun also muss den
Anspruch auch irgendwie erfüllen den man
selber stellt jetzt halten wir den
Gedanken mal kurz fest und reden gleich
weiter aber liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer wir müssen was nachholen
nämlich Sie herzlich willkommen heißen
zu unserem Gipfeltag hier vom
20 Gipfel in Delhi wir sind gespannt was
bei diesem Gipfel rauskommt und wir
wollten ihn mal unterschiedliche
Perspektiven bieten eben vom Brüssel
Korrespondent Ulf Röller vom
hauptstadtkorrespondenz an die Künast
und natürlich Normen Odenthal
langjähriger Korrespondent in Singapur
der diese Region sehr gut kennt man muss
erwähnen du warst auch in Peking in
China für mehrere Jahre und ich bin eben
der Korrespondent für Nord- und
Mittelamerika für sehr viel Washington
Elmar tebison und bevor wir jetzt weiter
reden gucken wir uns einfach mal an wie
wir hier eigentlich arbeiten und da hat
Ulf mal was mitgebracht
also hier beginnt der ganze Spaß für den
Gipfel hier treffen sich alle
Journalisten die zum Tagungsort wollen
und dann beginnt ein wirklicher
Hindernislauf und dafür braucht man
viele Dinge um am Ende angepflanzt zu
kommen einmal
eine Akkreditierung mit einem doch
ziemlich scheußlichen Bild man braucht
eine Kappe gegen die wahnsinnig brutale
Sonne das ganze quippment und man muss
jetzt durch unheimlich viele
sicherheitskranken hindurch und wenn man
Glück hat kommt man in einer Stunde an
also los geht's
[Musik]
überall ist der Chef zu sehen
das schwierigste ist bei diesem Gipfeln
irgendwie Heil mit dem ganzen Zeug
anzukommen
Berichterstattung dagegen einfach es ist
so heiß
werden
eine ganze Armada von Kameras sind hier
jede Region aus Indien hat man uns
erzählt hat mindestens ein bis zwei
Teams geschickt so stolz ist man dass
der Gipfel in Indien ist
eine der wichtigsten Fragen auf dem
Gipfel ist immer wie ist das Buffet und
wo ist das Buffet
hier sitzen meistens die
Printjournalisten von den Zeitungen und
da hinten da gehen wir gleich hin sind
die Boxen
[Musik]
die das sagt man ist das viel Zeug ja
was haben wir denn alles hier
was sehen wir ja wir können uns zwei
Studios aus Washington aus
dementsprechend zwei Schnittplätze und
die wollen natürlich alle auf das
Material zugreifen das heißt ich sitze
hier und habe einen Server bei einen
kleinen der unterm Tisch steht
wo alles Material drauf kommt wichtig
immer für uns wie gut ist das Internet
oder wie gut ist es diesmal bisher sehr
gut das stimmt da hängt immer mehr davon
ab weil immer mehr über das Internet
läuft und was ist der schlimmste
Albtraum den du dir vorstellen kannst
dass wir kein Internet haben oder
Stromausfall oder sowas ohne Strom haben
wir natürlich auch ein Problem also
einiges läuft
kommen wir zu der Abteilung
die sagen wie wichtig alles ist Julia
ist der wievielte Gipfel von dir ach das
kann nicht genau sagen seit 20 Jahren
mache ich Gipfel und was ist besonders
an diesem Gipfel oder was überhaupt
besonders an Gipfeln ja das Besondere
ist dass wir hier die Bilder halt
mitzeichnen dann die Stücke machen dass
wir auch hinter die Kulissen gucken
können das finde ich am aller
spannendsten dass man irgendwie nebenbei
viele balletals hat gucken kann wer
trifft wen und vor allem auch wer trifft
wie nicht das ist nämlich auch
interessant das ist die Abteilung
Brüssel
Amerika Annette macht das auch schon
sehr und die Frage die alle interessiert
die vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig
ist wie findest den beiden fit im Kopf
ist er auf jeden Fall und sonst ist er
halt ein
älterer Herr der etwas schief und etwas
langsam läuft aber
die Sorge ist in Amerika natürlich
grundsätzlich groß das ist das große
Thema das jetzt anlaufenden Wahlkampfes
wie fit ist der Präsident
über die Frage wie lang Joe Biden noch
durchhält macht sich ja nun wirklich
jeder Gedanken und man wird da immer
nachgefragt wir streiten und reden
häufig darüber hilft oder
ja nochmal als du gesagt hast dass
Amerika einen neuen politischen Stil
pflegt ein mehr gemeinsam habe ich
gedacht gucken wir mal was ist wenn
Donald Trump Tram kommt das ist ja auch
Amerika und das ist glaube ich noch mal
zu dem Thema auch Europa und die
Schwierigkeit ohne die Amerikaner wäre
dieser Krieg in der Ukraine schon längst
vorbei Europa das weiß jeder sagt ja
auch jeder Regierungschef hat nicht die
politische und schon gar nicht die
militärische Kraft irgendetwas zu
bewegen und ich glaube das größte und
die größte Gefahr für eine ja Kontinent
oder für Europa ist das die eigene
Sicherheit nicht selbst mehr hergestellt
werden kann ist ein langer Prozess es
gab immer die Sehnsucht nach einer
europäischen Armee hat man nie geschafft
sondern sich auf den großen Bruder in
Amerika verlassen und nun wackelt das
und jeder denkt oh Gott oh Gott und zur
Hoffnung hängt an einem 80-jährigen und
das ist natürlich sehr sehr gefährlich
insofern gucken alle auf diese Wahl weil
sie Schicksalswahl für Europa
aber das würde ich euch leider nicht
ganz gerne fragen oder euch dazu hören
wenn wir vom wenn du vom Niedergang des
Westens sprichst ist es dann letzten
Endes doch wieder der zentrale Faktor
USA und für möglicherweise tatsächlich
die nächste Wahl die darüber maßgeblich
entscheidet ist Europa sozusagen wieder
nur Seiten Aspekt eines solchen
Niedergangs und muss hinnehmen was da
passiert
das interessante für mich gerade zu
beobachten ist dass ich alle Sorgen
machen um Amerika aber dass die beiden
Administrationen
ziemlich ich sag mal gut versucht die
Dinge zu verändern also Amerika wieder
stark zu machen weil sie genau weiß wenn
Amerika schwach ist dann haben die
autoritären Regime hat der
Autoritarismus am Ende gewonnen und dazu
gehört für beiden eben eine
Industrie und Wirtschaftspolitik von
denen manche sagen die Europäer sollten
sich mal eine Scheibe davon abschneiden
dass man ganz gezielt die Industrie
Basis wieder ausbaut dass man dafür
sorgt dass Menschen wieder Perspektiven
haben dass sie besser bezahlte Jobs
haben und all das aber der beiden weiß
glaube ich sehr genau wenn er die
nächste Wahl verliert
dann stehen die Europäer alleine da wenn
Donald Trump oder ein anderer
Republikaner Präsident würde und
deswegen versucht er glaube ich die
ganze Zeit auch Berlin an die immer zu
sagen hey ihr müsst euren Akt jetzt
zusammenkriegen weil wir können nicht
garantieren dass Amerika für die
nächsten 10 20 Jahre die Führungsmacht
oder die führende macht im Bündnis ist
Deutschland ist ja ein schlüsselstart in
der EU und ehrlich gesagt ist es schon
ein bisschen frustrierend zu sehen
zumindest von außen wie wenig sich
Berlin auf die Möglichkeit vorbereitet
das Trump wiederkommt also wenn wir es
mal politisch sehen dass zwei Prozent
Ziel das versprochen wurde ab sofort
einzuhalten dieses Jahr wieder nicht
eingehalten soll jetzt angeblich erst ab
nächsten Jahr eingehalten werden und
überhaupt während sich die USA ja
strategischer aufstellen es geht ja
nicht nur um Werte sondern die USA die
mir jetzt auch Geld in die Hand und dem
globalen Süden ähm
Gegenangebot zu machen zu diesem
chinesischen Angebot die deutschen die
hören immer wenn da irgendeine aus dem
Entwicklungsland kommt die sagen den
immer wenn die Chinesen da waren haben
wir dann nach dem Flughafen wenn ihr da
wart haben wir dann nach dem Vortrag und
das ist glaube ich noch nicht angekommen
in Deutschland dass wir mit denen dass
wir zuhören müssen diesen Ländern und
dass wir mit denen auch auf Augenhöhe
reden müssen mich wird noch mal
interessieren wie der Bundeskanzler auch
Europas sieht du reist ja nun viel mit
ihm sieht er das eigentlich als seine
Aufgabe wie früher das Deutschland
versucht die Führungsnation in Europa zu
sein oder sieht er das vielleicht sogar
als Belastung dass man immer kritisiert
wird und die anderen damit auch
verbinden führungsnationen mehr Geld
mehr Geld mehr Geld mir ist das nicht so
ganz klar ehrlich gesagt nicht
ja es ist auch schwer zu beurteilen weil
er selber sieht sich ja als jemand der
führt und er sieht sich auch als jemand
der Europa führt er wird ja auch dafür
gelobt muss man auch sagen beiden lobt
ihn ständig für seine Führungsrolle
selbstzellensky lobt ihn für seine
Führungsrolle aber wenn ich an die
früheren
Bundesregierungen denke da war die Achse
da war das Verhältnis zu Frankreich viel
viel besser das ist ja im Prinzip
ziemlich angekratzt es gab früher das
Weimarer Dreieck eigentlich den Versuch
das Berlin Warschau und ähm Paris
zusammen vorangehen das sehe ich auch
nicht mehr im Gegenteil Scholz ist ja
immer wieder kritisiert worden dafür
dass er alleine entscheidet dass er
lange nicht entscheidet dass er wenn er
über die Waffenlieferung für die Ukraine
entscheidet auf die Amerikaner erwartet
also ein besonders europäischen Kanzler
sehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
ich finde unsere eigene Diskussion ein
bisschen entlarvend weil es zeigt dass
der Westen wieder sehr um sich selbst
dreht wir beschäftigen uns mit uns
selbst in fragen uns wie kommen wir da
vorwärts oder wo kommen wir da hin die
Zeit läuft und Partner vermeintliche
Partner wie Indien geben uns die Zeit
nicht mehr ewig die wollen was von uns
sehen und beispielsweise immer
beispielsweise wenn wir von von außen
gucken und sagen warum macht Indien nach
wie vor Waffengeschäfte mit Russland
warum holen Sie sich die waffenaffen
ja natürlich die warten darauf dass Sie
von uns was besseres oder anderes
geboten kriegen sonst vorher wird es
keinen Schritt geben in die ein oder
andere Richtung aber ist das ich meine
man hat ein bisschen den Eindruck auch
ein Basar Hier ich meine gestern Abend
hat sich Modi mit beiden getroffen die
haben 29 Punkte miteinander besprochen
wo sie überall zusammenarbeiten alle
Bereiche von Hochtechnologie bis zum
Kampf gegen den Klimawandel heute werden
sie wahrscheinlich miteinander
besprechen dass ein riesiges
Eisenbahnprojekt aufgeschient wird im
Wasser des Wortes von Indien über den
Nahen Osten nach Europa also versucht
den genommen der Westen
den globalen Süden zu kaufen und wird
hier gehandelt wo man das beste
rausschlägt und dann haben wir trotzdem
am Ende wieder die Zweiteilung weil dann
haben wir zwei Lager die die sich mit
dem Westen da zusammen tun und
vielleicht auf der anderen Seite China
und Russland oder wollt will der globale
Süden was anderes will deine multipolare
Welt der globale Süden ist natürlich
schon mal so ein Begriff der der sehr
wackelig ist und nicht so richtig gut
funktioniert glaube ich wenn wir bei
Indien reden die sagen einem hier sehr
deutlich also wir machen das was wir uns
am besten ist wir machen Geschäfte mit
Russland wir machen Geschäfte mit Europa
mit den Amerikanern wir machen das was
für Indien gut ist und das sagen sie
unverblüten und ohne schlechtes Gewissen
wie wir vielleicht vermuten würden ne
sondern sie gucken auf sich selbst und
das Tun an andere Länder die wir so zum
globalen Süden ordnen glaube ich auch
das ist gleichzeitig natürlich eine
Schwäche dieses globalen Südens das ist
der Punkt immer von schon mal kurz hat
auch und das ist für mich auch noch ein
Thema Singflug ist vielleicht ein
bisschen radikal aber wir müssen auch
hier ein bisschen
bisschen Action machen damit jemand
zuhört sondern sagen wir
Schrumpfungsprozess Europa und auch
Amerika bei Europa war immer sehr stolz
auf seine Werte das war ein Teil diese
exportieren wollten die Sichtweise freie
Menschen freie Kultur Demokratie sollte
ein Verkaufsschlager sein aus Indien
würde ich sagen empfinden die das als
Arroganz oder empfinden sie das noch
irgendetwas was anstrebenswert ist in
europäischen Weg zu regieren und zu
leben die haben alle ihre Geschichte sie
haben auch ein Teil europäische
Geschichte tragen sie mit sich rum das
nicht das beste Kapitel der
Kolonialismus hat seine Spuren
hinterlassen bis heute würde ich sagen
und das ist so zwiegespalten man hätte
gern das Gute was man durchaus sieht aus
vergangenen Zeiten bewahrt aber man will
sich auch distanzieren und das von oben
herab jemanden erklärt dass einer
erklärt ihm ist es so und so machen dass
unsere Werte für die wir stehen das
kommt in einem Land das soll eine
Geschichte mit sich rum trägt nicht
besonders gut an
aber es ist dann eine Abkehr von ich
meine wir haben nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg eine Weltordnung erlebt
gemeinsam erschaffen aber vorangetrieben
vor allen Dingen von den USA und den
Europäern die im Grunde genommen auf
Prinzipien beruht die Menschenrechte
auch die Chance Entwicklungen
voranzutreiben für die Menschen
natürlich auch internationaler freier
Handel und dazu gehören auch solche
Dinge wie Souveränität und
territoriale Integrität
soll diese Weltordnung jetzt abgelöst
werden also abgeschafft werden richtig
man hat den Eindruck China Wilders aber
wollen die anderen Länder wie Indien das
eigentlich auch und es steht an oberster
Stelle dann nur wir wollen Entwicklung
haben und wenn der Autoritarismus uns da
besser zum Ziel führt dann wer will dann
schon nach liberale Demokratie oder
Menschenrechte ich glaube das noch nicht
das sieht im Moment so aus im Moment ist
der Westen wirklich eine defensive also
auch wir sehen ja was in Afrika passiert
ein gewählte Regierung nach der wird er
weggeputscht und so weiter aber wir
machen uns manchmal auch mehr so ein
lustig bisschen lustig über die Werte
und den Werte Westen und so weiter aber
der hat einen riesige Anziehungskraft
für die Leute
Hollywood Kinofilme die Sprache Englisch
das ist ja alles für die für die
normalen Leute da und die sehen ja auch
dass die Führer die Anführer des das
globalen Westens sich an der Macht
halten weil sie ihre Gegner vom Himmel
schießen in der Botschaft zersägen
lassen oder mit militärput wegschießen
ich glaube
dass wir da die die westlichen Werte
noch nicht abschreiben sollten und ich
glaube auch dass die Anziehungskraft auf
Dauer größer sein wird als das was jetzt
im Moment sehen
ich widerspreche da nur ungern und ich
bin mir auch nicht sicher ob ich ja ob
ich da überhaupt recht habe aber meiner
Erfahrung in China war das ist mich doch
so schockiert hat wie gut Leute ohne
Demokratie auskommt das ist echt das was
sie am wenigsten vermissen sauberes
Wasser vielleicht ein Auto eine schöne
Wohnung Aufstieg Essen mal in Urlaub
fahren es sind sehr einfache Dinge und
das chinesische Modell ist ja das
Gegenteil zu Amerika wenn man es ganz
klassisch machen will das ist das Modell
die Partei sagt wo es lang geht und
dafür macht und ihr halte den Mund und
dafür machen wir Euch reich oder wohl
habend das hat ja sehr sehr funktioniert
und Chichi Ping würde sogar sagen
dadurch dass einer sagt wo es lang geht
ist viel mehr Dynamik zu schaffen weil
diese endlosen Diskussion die wir in
Amerika sehen also eine neue Regierung
bedeutet gleich wer der weniger was
völlig anderes oder die vielen Meinungen
Europa die da rumschwirren und bisschen
man Konsens das ist für ihn ist langsam
und es ist für ihn nicht entschlossen
genug und er glaubt eben dass dieses
Prinzip besser funktioniert wir liefern
euch wirklich ihr werdet Wohlhaben mit
uns ihr könnt vielleicht nicht wählen
und noch mal erschrocken war ich doch
dass das viele Menschen überhaupt nicht
vermissen leider noch eine kurze
Gegenrede dazu wo geben denn die Saudis
ihr Geld aus wo schicken denn die
Chinesen ihre Kinder hin auf die Schule
also das ist natürlich dann wieder wo
wollen Sie Ihre Willen haben ja in
Südfrankreich und so weiter also das ist
meine Widerrede noch mal
jetzt verführen die Europäer du erlebst
das mit in verschiedenen europäischen
Ländern haben wir eine sehr starke
rechtspopulistische Bewegung wir haben
in Deutschland die AFD an die das kannst
du super beurteilen und basiert doch
alles im Grunde auf dem einen Punkt
nämlich die Menschen wollen dass der
Staat seine seinen Teil des Vertrages
erfüllt den man mit ihm hat nämlich wenn
wir Steuern zahlen und unsere Stimmen
abgeben dann muss der Staat einige
Grundprinzipien gewährleisten das sind
Freiheit das sind die
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten das ist auch
Sicherheit und all geringe und manche
Menschen in Europa auch in den USA haben
das Gefühl das tut der Staat nicht mehr
während offenbar Menschen in China und
anderswo auch in Afrika in Ruanda
beispielsweise oder Senegal das Gefühl
haben doch die tun das auch wenn Sie ein
bisschen autoritärer daherkommen das
sind absolut richtigen Punkt das ist ja
fast bizarr dass die Tochter von Chichi
Ping so weit man das weiß in Harvard
studiert hat das ist bekannt ja und
dafür gibt es viele Beispiele ja selbst
lavrovski Kinder sind glaube ich
irgendwo in England wenn es richtig
gesehen habe und eben nicht da wo die
anderen leben müssen ja ich glaube schon
das ist so eine Stärke China ist dass
sie vielleicht weiß nicht wie das für
Indien ist gucken was bei uns stark ist
Bildungssystem freier Geist freies
Denken erzeugt natürlich große
Kreativität dann nehmen Sie das auf ich
würde umgekehrt halt sagen wir müssen
auch mal gucken was dort stark ist ja
und nicht sagen wir haben die Werte und
deswegen sind wir also mehr der weniger
per se schon auf dem richtigen Weg das
ist vielleicht das Abonnement da bin ich
voll bei hier ehrlich gesagt weil das
ist der Eindruck jedenfalls auch wenn
man in Asien lebt und das hast du dann
eben wahrscheinlich ähnlich erfahren wie
ich dass wir von Europa aus oder vom
Westen aus doch immer noch ziemlich von
oben herunter gucken und sagen wir
wissen halt wie es geht wir haben es wir
machen es euch vor aber wir müssen
merken dass das nicht mehr der Fall ist
die sind teilweise einfach an uns vorbei
gezogen und wir sind die die hinten
dranhängen in vielen Bereichen und
dieses als ersten Schritt mal zu
realisieren das würde glaube ich auch
gelegentlich auf seiner
gipfelveranstaltung helfen ich bin aber
da schon bei Andi ein bisschen mehr dass
ich sage das verstehe ich und das ist
auch super dass man
da eigentlich ein Konsens haben müsste
dass die Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten im
Vordergrund stehen aber Europa hat ja
bewiesen über Jahrzehnte nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg das ist das
erfolgreichste Modell überhaupt
wirtschaftlich politisch freiheitlich
von den Rechten der Menschen her über so
viele Jahrzehnte nach einem verheerenden
Krieg all das zu garantieren weitgehend
jedenfalls für die Menschen das ist eben
ein Modell ist etwas an dem völlig
andere orientieren aber sie wollen es
vielleicht natürlich jetzt sehr schnell
haben und wir müssen verstehen dass wir
erheblich dazu beitragen müssen damit
das auch gelingt für den Rest der Welt
und wir müssen verstehen dass wir uns
auch immer wieder neu erfinden müssen im
Moment da hat Ulf recht sind wir einen
Punkt wo wir irgendwie in der Sackgasse
sind das ist ja kein Zufall
wahrscheinlich dass in das alle
westlichen Gesellschaften extrem
polarisiert sind was Trump in USA gehört
das den Streit brexit in in UK du hast
in Deutschland die AFD also im Prinzip
vielleicht ist auf Japan sind ja alle
großen westlichen Demokratien gerade in
derselben
im selben Dilemma und das muss ja ein
gemeinsamen Grund haben und da müssen
irgendwas passieren
jetzt auch in Europa genau die
Polarisierung wenn du ein Orban dir
anguckst der davon schwärmt in einem
Interview mit eine bekannten
Rechtsausleger takakarzin der Trump
interviewt hat und dann auch eben
Orban interviewt hat nicht Obama Orban
interviewt hat wir schwärmt von einer
Wiederkehr zurückkehr von Trump daran
siehst du wie das polarisiertes
Rechtsruck in Europa wie viel
Regierungen doch ein ganz anderen Kurs
Europa haben wollen als der jetzt
gängige insofern haben wir diese
Polarisierung Europa auch da ist ja auch
von Meloni dabei aus Italien was die
Frage natürlich aufwirft kriegen die das
überhaupt unter einem Hut also ist schon
Format wie geht's 20 überhaupt in der
Lage am Ende etwas zu produzieren was
allen gefällt oder hat sich das überlebt
und wir steuern im Grunde genommen auf
eine Welt zu wo es solche Foren
eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt wo man
die Dinge und ich kann nur allen sagen
die jetzt sagen der beste ist so
Abschwung und ähm jetzt kommt der
globale Süden viel Spaß in allen
Formaten mit Russland viel Spaß wir
kennen ja die Formate in den Russland
ist
Sicherheitsrat Russland vertritt immer
nur seine eigenen Interessen dort macht
nie irgendwas konstruktives OSZE
Russland blockiert Russland zahlt seine
Beiträge nicht Russland blockiert den
Haushalt Europarat ist Russland
rausgeflogen also wenn jetzt die bricks
sich noch erweitern wollen und
also alle die damit zu tun haben werden
auch lernen müssen dass das keine
konstruktive Zusammenarbeit ist während
die G7 ich bin ihr seid ja auch oft auf
die sieben treffen das ist wirklich auch
von der Atmosphäre her was anderes da
kommen die gegen ihre Handys ab machen
ihre Witzchen machen die Tür zu und
trauen sich mal was wäre wenn es denn da
hindurch zu spielen trauen sich mal ein
bisschen rumzuspielen kann man sich das
vorstellen wenn ich hier und Putin und
dreimal zusammensetzen
über das ja alles nicht sehr ermutigend
und trotzdem muss man ja irgendwie sagen
so ein Gipfel man hat ja das Gefühl es
ist gut wenn sie miteinander reden fragt
man sich bloß wie viel wird denn noch
geredet das was wir im Vorfeld sondern
Veranstaltung sehen ist ja schon das
permanente entschärfen der ganzen
Angelegenheit also man versucht er die
ganzen Klippen aus dem Weg zu holen ich
finde die Frage berechtigt was ist so
eine Veranstaltung so ein Gipfel da noch
wert was keiner bringen
ich fand das halt sie haben ja heute die
Afrikanische Union aufgenommen das war
das einzige Bild was uns gezeigt wurde
wie er dann emoji den Präsidenten der
Afrikanischen Union umarmte ja und ihn
mit in diese große g20-familie und das
war ja auf einer irgendwie wie ein
absurd weil wir kriegen vielleicht keine
Abschlusserklärung hier also eine
Familie was das Motto dieses Gipfels ist
stimmt hinten und vorne nicht zwei
wichtige Schlüsselfiguren putinski sind
gar nicht hier und man versucht weil man
weiß dass da eigentlich der Eindruck
einer Zerrissenheit eine Zerfaserung
dieser Welt ist und nicht klar ist wohin
sie geht versucht man gegen zu wirken
indem man jetzt die Afrikanische Union
so sinnvoll das sein mag aufnimmt und zu
zeigen ja irgendwas noch größer und noch
komplizierte aber ist dann Ping nicht
sauer stinke sauer da drüber dass Indien
im Grunde genommen sich als der Führer
des globalen Südens hier versucht zu
inszenieren während ich dabei ist
das natürlich immer schwer weil man ja
eigentlich nie die Gelegenheit hat
irgendwas von ihm zu hören ja das ist
Chinesen würden sagen du kannst doch mit
Gott nicht sprechen ja da musst du
einfach warten was passiert aber ich
würde sagen
ich glaube dass es stimmt er wollte sich
die Bühne mit den Amerikaner nicht
teilen das will er nicht er will ein
Zeichen setzen er will sich glaube ich
vielleicht sogar in gewisser Weise nicht
solidarisieren mit Putin all deine
optische gleitscheid schaffen indem er
nicht da ist und ich glaube für Gigi
Ping ist der viel wichtigere Gipfel
gewesen der brix-gipfel der von paar
Wochen stattgefunden hat wo sie alle
Händchen haltend waren und das ist seine
Agenda und wenn er hier ist weiß er
natürlich dass immer noch die Amerikaner
sehr dominieren kommen wir auch mit sehr
viel Geld wollen sie rein investieren in
den globalen Süden und da wollte er
einfach nicht quasi Beiwerk sein ich
glaube er sagt ich habe jetzt meine
eigene Bühne ich bin mein eigenes macht
Zentrum und ich signalisiere dass ich
diese alte Weltordnung die von den
Amerikanern geführt wird so nicht mehr
akzeptiere eigentlich ein guter Schluss
nur der liebe Gott weiß letztendlich was
passiert und wir können eigentlich nur
zuschauen was jetzt hier in Deli
beschlossen wird genug geredet Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer wir
bedanken uns ganz herzlich für ihr
interesse namaste
aus dir